When it comes time for Pandas to mate… scientists
turn on the porn.
Panda porn, to be exact.
And while this sounds strange, it makes sense
considering the difficulties of Wild Sex in
captivity.
Female pandas are gregarious and beautiful
creatures.
They also represent a unique combination of
two important things: One, they are a charismatic
animal that humans love, and two, they are
critically endangered in the wild.
Animal scientists have been trying for decades
to ‘help’ female pandas with their sex
lives, and although they sometimes complies
with the desires of their human friends, they
would rather spend their time relaxing panda-style.
In the wild, pandas are solitary and tend
to remain within their own territories.
When females come into estrus - which happens
just one time per year - they will roam the
outskirts of their home and deposit secretions
from their anus to alert potential mates to
their state of ‘readiness’.
In doing this, females attract the attention
of nearby males, and the female climbs a tree
whilst the males duke it out for the chance
to copulate with her.
In this way, the female can make a legitimate
choice about her reproductive partner - mating
only with the trophy male she prefers.
However, such luxuries are not usually a part
of the sex lives of pandas in captivity.
Females in zoos worldwide are either mated
with a male from another zoo, or artificially
inseminated.
How romantic.
This is because humans have traditionally
had a lack of understanding of the importance
of female choice.
Female pandas, like female humans, are more
likely to become pregnant with a preferred
partner.
Some breeding programs have therefore gone
to additional extents to encourage the process
along.
Things like panda porn.
Scientists have found that watching the process
can help but only if a female finds the right
suitor.
When several males are presented to a female,
but separated from her through a fence-type
barrier, she can choose which male she likes
best.
Since this panda was raised in captivity,
she hasn’t actually seen what it looks like
when a male and female panda copulate.
So the lovebirds are entertained and educated
by videos depicting other panda couples engaged
in the action.
Although it sounds like an exercise in ridiculousness,
the fact of the matter is, panda porn can
actually work with the right partner.
Or at least it doesn’t seem to hurt.
If you want to see more copulation creations,
check out this Wild Sex playlist!
Let us know in the comments what animal sex
stories you want to see.
If you want more stories right now, grab a
copy of the book Wild Sex, written by me,
Dr. Carin Bondar.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!